>> DO YOU HAVE ANY PLANS TO
VISIT THE BORDER?
>> WE’VE BEEN TO THE BORDER.
SO THIS WHOLE THING ABOUT THE
BORDER --
>> YOU HAVEN’T BEEN TO THE
BORDER.
>> AND I HAVEN’T BEEN TO EUROPE
I MEAN, I DON’T UNDERSTAND THE
POINT THAT YOU’RE MAKING.
I’M NOT DISCOUNTING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE BORDER.
>> WELL I KNOW REPUBLICANS HAVE
CERTAINLY VINCEED YOU ON THIS
BUT DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN
AS A BORDER DISTRICT SAID TO YOU
AND THE PRESIDENT, COME.
>> I CARE ABOUT, LISTEN I CARE
ABOUT WHAT’S HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER.
I’M IN GUATEMALA BECAUSE MY
FOCUS IS DEALING WITH THE ROOT
CAUSES OF MIGRATION.
THERE MAY BE SOME WHO THINK THAT
THAT IS NOT IMPORTANT BUT IT IS
MY FIRM BELIEF THAT IF WE CARE
ABOUT WHAT’S HAPPENING AT THE
BORDER, WE BETTER CARE ABOUT THE
ROOT CAUSES, AND ADDRESS
THEM.
AINSLEY: LET’S BRING IN
LOUISIANA SENATOR JOHN KENNEDY
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SENATOR.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING.
SO, EVERYONE HAS BEEN ASKING,
WHEN IS SHE GOING TO GO TO THE
BORDER ITS BEEN 76 DAYS SINCE
SHE WAS APPOINTED AS THE BORDER
CZAR, YET SHE’S YET TO GO TO THE
BORDER, AND LESTER HOLT PRESSED
HER ON IT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT HER
ANSWER?
SHE SAYS WE HAVE BEEN AND HE
PRESSED AND SAID NO, YOU REALLY
HAVEN’T BEEN.
>> WELL I THINK MOST AMERICANS
CAN SEE WHAT’S GOING ON HERE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
BELIEVES IN OPEN BORDERS, AND
MAY SAY OTHERWISE, BUT MOST OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT I’VE TALKED
TO BELIEVE THAT VETTING PEOPLE
AT THE BORDER IS RACIST.
THEY DON’T, THEY SUPPORT LEGAL,
ILLEGAL AND LEGAL IMMIGRATION.
MOST AMERICANS SUPPORT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION BUT THEY DON’T
SUPPORT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, BUT
I THINK THAT THE REASON THE VICE
PRESIDENT WENT TO GUATEMALA AND
MET WITH THE PRESIDENT IS TO
OFFER HIM BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF AMERICAN TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
TRY TO MAKE HIS COUNTRY BETTER,
AND WITH NO DISRESPECT BUT
THAT’S LIKE GIVING WHISKEY AND
CAR KEYS TO A TEENAGER.
THE PRESIDENT IS AN
AUTHORITARIAN.
HE PRESIDES OVER A CORRUPT
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE PROBABLY GOING TO STEAL
THE MONEY.
CORRUPTION IS RAMPANT.
THE DRUG CARTELS WORK OR  RUN
THINGS AND FRANKLY, THE
PRESIDENT WANTS HIS PEOPLE
TO COME TO AMERICA BECAUSE THEY
COME HERE AND THEY GET THROUGH
ILLEGALLY, THEY GET A JOB AND
THEY SEND MONEY BACK HOME, WHICH
HELPS THE GDP OF GUATEMALA.
NOW, YOU DON’T HAVE TO BE
EINSTEIN’S COUSIN TO FIGURE ALL
OF THIS OUT.
BRIAN:  SENATOR, HER ANSWER WAS
SO INAPPROPRIATE AND SO
INADEQUATE.
I THINK IT NEEDS TO BE
UNDERLINED.
SHE SAID I DIDN’T GO TO EUROPE
EITHER, AND THEN GIGGLES?
AND THEN SAYS WE’VE BEEN TO THE
BORDER, NO YOU HAVEN’T.
I MEAN, IT’S AS IF SHE DIDN’T
PRE-THINK IT.
IT REMINDS ME OF WHEN SHE WAS A
CANDIDATE AND FAILED SO
PRECIPITOUSLY BUT IN THE BIG
PICTURE THEY CAN’T BE HAPPY WITH
WHAT’S HAPPENING.
170,000 PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER.
MILITARY BASES BEING CONVERTED.
OTHER STRUCTURES BEING PUT UP.
MONEYS COMING POURING OUT.
IN ONE WAY IT’S A SIMPLE ANSWER
TO SAY THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS
BUT I THINK IT’S MORE COMPLEX
THAN THAT.
ARE THEY JUST IN COMPETENT?
>> NO.
I THOUGHT AT FIRST THEY WERE,
BUT I’M CONVINCED NOW THAT THEY
BELIEVE IN OPEN BORDERS, AND IN
SOME PART, IT’S BECAUSE SOME
MEMBERS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION JUST THINK THEY
ARE SYMPATHETIC.
THEY THINK ANYBODY WANTS TO COME
TO AMERICA SHOULD BE ABLE TO.
OTHERS TAKE A MORE CYNICAL VIEW
AND IT’S ABOUT VOTES AND POWER.
IT’S DANGEROUS, I CAN TELL YOU
THAT.
WE HAVE PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD, NOT JUST NICARAGUA
AND GUATEMALA AND
EL SALVADOR, WE HAVE PEOPLE FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD TRYING TO
MAKE THEIR WAY TO MEXICO SO THEY
CAN COME INTO THE UNITED STATES
OF MENTIONER AND WE DON’T HAVE
THE SLIGHTEST IDEA WHAT THEY ARE
GOING TO DO AND WHAT THEY DO
WHEN THEY GET HERE AND THAT’S
NOT A PRUDENT WAY TO RUN AN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
I DON’T KNOW ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
WORLD WHO DOES IT THAT WAY
EXCEPT THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
STEVE: WE’RE NUMBER ONE IN THAT
DEPARTMENT.
HEY, SENATOR, YOUR COLLEAGUE
FROM WEST VIRGINIA, JOE MANCHIN,
IS GETTING A LOT OF PUBLICITY.
>> UH-HUH.
STEVE: BECAUSE OVER THE WEEKEND
HE WROTE AN OP-ED FOR A LOCAL
PAPER OUT IN WEST VIRGINIA WHERE
HE SAID THAT HE WOULD VOTE
AGAINST THE FOR THE PEOPLE ACT,
WHICH WAS, YOU KNOW, WOULD
ESSENTIALLY FEDERALIZE ALL
ELECTIONS IN THE FACE OF THE
CONSTITUTION AND THE
HEADLINES HAVE BEEN, HE’S
REALLY GOTTEN BAKED OVER AT CNN
THEY SAY JOE MANCHIN TOTALLY
SCREWED DEMOCRATS, WASHINGTON
POST AND THE OPINION PAGE, JOE
MANCHIN RETREATS TO FANTASYLAND
AND STICKS AMERICA
WITH THE CONSEQUENCES.
YOU KNOW, HE’S BEEN VERY CLEAR
FROM THE GET-GO HE DOES NOT WANT
TO BLOW UP THE FILIBUSTER
BECAUSE IF YOU BLOW UP THE
FILIBUSTER YOU ESSENTIALLY
BLOW UP THE SENATE.
>> WELL HERE IS WHAT I THINK IS
GOING ON AND YOU’RE CORRECT.
SENATOR MANCHIN, THEY HIT HIM
WITH EVERYTHING BUT A CHAIR.
THEY CALLED HIM EVERY NAME IN
THE BOOK.
THEY HAVEN’T STARTED TALKING
ABOUT HIS MOMMA YET BUT THEY
PROBABLY WILL.
HERE IS WHAT I THINK IS GOING ON
THIS ISN’T A NEWS FLASH.
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY TOOK A HARD LEFT AND KEPT
DRIVING.
THERE ARE TWO GROUPS IN CHARGE.
THE WOKE RACISTS WHO HAVE
CONTEMPT FOR AMERICA AND THE
MANAGERIAL ELITE WHO HAVE
CONTEMPT FOR THE AMERICAN MIDDLE
CLASS.
I REFER TO THEM AS THE VANILLA
SOY EXTRA FOAM LATTE CROWD.
SENATOR MANCHIN IS NOT A MEMBER
OF EITHER ONE OF THOSE GROUPS
AND HE’S BEEN AROUND THIS PLACE
A LONG TIME AND MY EXPERIENCE
WITH JOE IS HE’S CENTROID, HE
EXERCISES POWER MATERIALLY AND
HE UNDERSTANDS THAT IF WE GET
RID OF THE FILIBUSTER IT
WILL BLOW UP THE SENATE.
YOU DON’T THINK THAT THE
MINORITY PARTY, IN THIS CASE
REPUBLICANS, IF SCHUMER GETS RID
OF THE FILIBUSTER ARE JUST GOING
TO GO QUIETLY INTO THAT
GOODNIGHT.
EVERY REACTION HAS AN EQUAL AND
OPPOSITE REACTION.
BRIAN:  RIGHT.
YOU GUYS MIGHT LEAVE OUT, YOU
MIGHT STORM OUT AND NOT GIVE HIM
A QUORUM.
>> THE INTERESTING THING, BRIAN
, IS THAT SENATOR SCHUMER
DOESN’T QUITE KNOW HOW TO HANDLE
THIS.
YOU KNOW, THAT FEELING WHEN YOU
GET UP IN THE MORNING AND YOU’VE
GOT TO GO TO THE BATHROOM BUT
YOU DON’T WANT TO GET OUT OF BED
THAT’S KIND OF WHERE CHUCK IS.
HE JUST DOESN’T QUITE KNOW WHAT
TO DO HERE AND IF I WERE CHUCK,
--
BRIAN:  I’D GET OUT OF BED.
>> I’D GET OUT OF BED AND WHEN
ONE DOOR CLOSES HE’S NOT GOING
TO BUST THE FILIBUSTER.
WHEN ONE DOOR CLOSES SOMETIMES
YOU NEED TO GET A HAMMER AND
NAILS AND MAKE SURE THAT SOB
STAYS SHUT AND MOVE ON.
THAT’S WHAT CHUCK OUGHT TO DO.
STEVE: YOU KNOW, WE ALWAYS LEARN
A LOT ABOUT YOU, SENATOR, DURING
YOUR VISITS.
>> [LAUGHTER]
STEVE: WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR JOINING US AND WE LOOK